après des années d'efforts il est devenu
le plus noble des parisiens allocation
quelles sont vos influences
oh je dirais principalement nous mène
jusqu'au jour où il a connu pas mon
frère charges qui a une antenne nous
chez tous une grosse rechute
voyez ne s'exprime pas encore bien
normalement mais chic et beaubourg je
suis parent doit normalement avec
thanachart parigot la catégorie chez pas
mis chez l'autre bonjour madame très
confus 1
ça n'a rien d'étonnant de vider une
partie de sa vie où se rappeler d'une
autre c'est je crois qu'on peut dire la
vérité maintenant moments faibles à dos
marié coup mais elle est déjà mariée
avec lui
mais ils étaient ensemble cacher pour
commettre dans le 6e
le terminal peu près en somme non pas en
sixième
en tout cas